no hay rastro de Vladimir Putin en la
emisión de la televisión Estatal rusa en
la que suministro de defensa ordena La
retirada de la ciudad de ucraniana de
gerson la única capital regional que
Moscú ha capturado desde el comienzo de
su invasión
comprendo que se trata de una decisión
muy incómoda al mismo tiempo salvaremos
las vidas de nuestros militares y la
capacidad de combate de nuestras tropas
sergi Vladimir estoy de acuerdo con sus
conclusiones y sugerencias empiece a
retirar las tropas y tome todas las
medidas para garantizar el traslado
seguro del personal las armas y el
equipo a través del Río nieper
los rusos anunciaron el establecimiento
una nueva línea defensiva al este del
níper sin embargo las autoridades
ucranianas se muestran cautelosas ante
estas órdenes escenificadas con el
asesor presidencial advirtiendo que no
ven señales de que Rusia vaya a dejar
gerson sin luchar las fuerzas de que se
han concentrado en la ciudad y han
cortado las líneas de suministro como
parte de una contraofensiva mayor en el
este y el sur de Ucrania que ha hecho
retroceder a las tropas rusas
salimos al combate dos o tres veces al
día disparando toda la carga de munición
unos 50 o 60 disparos al día seguramente
disparamos contra los vehículos de
Infantería ligera y las tropas de tierra
los rusos no están poniendo su equipo
militar Pesado
jerson fue una de las cuatro regiones
que Rusia declaró haber anexionado en
septiembre su retirada de la capital
regional pone en peligro su control del
resto de la zona que forma un puente
terrestre de Rusia hasta crimea
ante el avance ucraniano Moscú ya había
ordenado la evacuación de los civiles de
la ciudad unas 115.000 personas
reubicándolas en los territorios
ocupados por Rusia en el este del país